JOHN ZERATSKY: My name
is John Zeratsky.
I'm a User Experience Designer
at YouTube where I work
on tools for video
creators and curators.
Before that I was working on
advertising tools at Google.
And prior to that I was working
for a start-up in Chicago
called FeedBurner, which
is where I met my
friend Matt Shobe.
MATT SHOBE: Hi, I'm Matt Shobe.
I was one of the co-founders
with FeedBurner and I was our
Director of User Experience.
All aspects of user experience
involved in from designing on
the front end to writing a lot
of the copy for the site.
A lot of communication.
Lot of explaining to do at
various parts of FeedBurner
and also providing
direct customer support.
So the end to end user
experience was a big part of my
and John's lives at that time.
And I think the principles,
tips, techniques, bits, and
pieces we've got to talk about
with you today-- although we
really derived those during
this kind of startupy
experience with FeedBurner we
feel that they apply to
whatever size organization
you might be from.
From four guys in a van all the
way up to a major corporation.
So I think they should
work fairly well for that
purpose and are we bit.ly?
There we go.
The back-channel as I think
all these talks have.
There it is so hop in and
we'll look forward to
the questions later.
Take it away.
JOHN ZERATSKY: All right, so
as we said this is a talk
about user experience.
It's not exactly a
talk about design.
At least not in the
traditional sense.
So what's the difference?
When most people think about
user experience they think
about usability, user interface
design, interaction design.
And these are very
important things.
I mean, this is what we do most
of the time in our day jobs and
it also makes up the core of
the experience that people
have using your products.
But it doesn't end there.
There's so many other things
that affect the user experience
that don't fall into
that category of design.
And that's what we want
to talk about today.
So we've get seven principles
and a handful of concrete tips
scattered throughout that will
have you create experiences
that will delight and serve
and engage your users.
And there are things that you
can do even if nobody in your
organization has designer
in their job title.
We think that these are tips
that anyone could use.
So the first one is simple, but
it's very, very important.
Which is why we start out
with it, is to be fast.
And one of the reasons we like
to talk about this first is
that it kind of emphasizes the
point we're trying to make
here, which is that you've got
these technical factors that
impact the user experience.
They don't fall under the
umbrella of design, but they
really, really matter to the
people who are using
your software.
So our first tip is
to focus on latency.
Basic stuff.
Pages should load quickly.
Users shoud get immediate
feedback when they
do something.
Your app should feel
snappy, generally.
And it's not just about
user experience.
This stuff can have a big
impact on your business.
We've got a case study
here from Mozilla.
Who recently optimized their
download page for Firefox.
The only change that they made
is they shaved about two
seconds off the page load time.
They didn't change
the way it looked.
They didn't change the way
it worked, this is the
only thing they did.
And what was the result?
They saw download conversions
improve by 15%, over 15%.
So this is an example of
the impact of latency.
It's not only on user
experience, but on business.
And you can check out they got
a blog post about this if you
follow that bit.ly link there.
Of course speed is very
important to Google.
Part of why people like
Google is that it's fast.
Search results load quickly
and you get to where
you're going very quickly.
In this slide I've used Firebug
to measure how long it took to
download and render this
page. 470 milliseconds.
That's pretty quick.
There are a lot of cool things
about Firebug, but one of the
really great things for
purposes of measuring latency
is the net tab there that
maybe you haven't seen.
That allows you to see exactly
how long it took every single
component of the page, the
markup, the CSS, the
JavaScript, the images to load.
And that's really interesting
when you're trying to
speed up your web app.
Beyond that, you know, detailed
advice on improving latency is
a bit beyond the scope of this
talk and we promise to talk
about user experience.
You can learn a lot about
making your application
fast throughout the
rest of the conference.
But I do want to mention a
few of the resources that
are really valuable.
Pagetest at webpagetest.org
allows you to analyze not only
a single webpage or a single
site and see what's
slowing it down.
But do comparisons
between multiple sites.
So you can actually watch how
pages are downloaded and
rendered in real time
or in slow motion.
You can create a video of
that too and I have a video
I'll show you in a second.
Page speed and YSlow
are very similar.
They're both add-ons to Firebug
that will analyze your page and
not only show you how long
things are taking to download,
but they'll compare your site
against the set of best
practices in the case of YSlow
developed at Yahoo and
the case of Page speed
developed at Google.
And they'll give you
advice on how to improve.
So as promised
I've got a video.
This is generated at
webpagetest.org and what I've
done is I put in the search
results page for Google, for
Bing and for Yahoo and what
we've going to do is we're
going to watch in slow motion
as each of these three pages
download and render.
So we're seeing time
at the bottom.
This is running slowly.
And you'll see that all three
search engines they load the
content in on the search
result page pretty quickly.
When they're finished loading
as in the case of Google and
Yahoo the page turns gray.
Bing is actually just loading a
background image and then it
finally finishes, but the
content was there from
about one second.
So you know, not trying to make
any point about the choices
that these teams made, but you
can see how this would be
useful for your own site.
Looking at that and seeing in
detail, OK, you know it's OK
if this big background
image doesn't load it.
It's OK if something that's
aesthetic mostly in nature
doesn't load as long as the
important content is there.
And even investors, well,
some of them are savvy
about this stuff.
Fred Wilson is a venture
capital investor whose been
involved with a lot of
successful companies and a lot
of unsuccessful ones too.
He says that speed is the
most important feature.
He's not an engineer, he's not
a designer, he's an investor
and he thinks that
this is true.
He brings up a great point
here, which is that speed
actually matters more to casual
mainstream users because they
don't know how hard it is for
your application to
be fast, right?
They just want it work.
The people in this room, you
know, power users and
developers, as Fred puts it,
we're a bit more sympathetic
to how difficult it is
to make a web app fast.
So we tend to tolerate
a little bit more when
we see a slow app.
So moving onto our
second tip about speed.
It's not enough for your
application to be fast.
You need to do things to
make your users fast, too.
There are a lot of little
shortcuts that you can provide
and I'll run through a bunch of
tips and examples to help you
make your users faster at
using your application.
If you don't pay attention to
those things, not only are you
going to slow people down, but
all those little things, day
after day, time after time are
going to add up and make the
experience just a little bit
more frustrating
for your users.
So as a very simple example to
start out, let's say we've got
a pages that's got a form on
it with four fields, right?
And you know that when people
get to that page-- let's say
it's like the compose screen
for sending an e-mail or
writing a message, right?
You know that they're going to
want to start typing in that
first field right away.
So a simple thing you can do,
very easy to implement is
automatically focus
that first field.
It's going to shave
half a second off.
People aren't going to have
to use the mouse to locate
and click on that field.
It's not going to change the
world, but it's going to make
your users lives just
a little bit better.
Here's an example from an
airline website where they're
remembering recent input.
So especially with airlines
this is actually a really smart
thing because you generally fly
between just a handful
of airports, right?
You're not flying all over
the world from and to many
different airports, so it's
useful to remember
the inputs here.
So rather than having again to
you know, locate that field and
type into it you can just
you know, pick one of the
selections that's already
there and be on your way.
And Matt pointed out another
sort of bonus example from
this case, which is that the
developers took the care to
actually use the HTML label
element around round trip and
one way so that you don't have
to find that tiny little radio
button and can click on that.
You can click anywhere on
that label and trigger
the selection you want.
Again, not going to change the
world, but it's a nice little
thing that's going to speed up
your users and make their
lives a little better.
MATT SHOBE: Yeah, big targets
are always better than small
targets when it comes to
using the mouse for sure.
JOHN ZERATSKY: Totally.
And exacerbated by
mobile devices.
MATT SHOBE: Yeah, definitely.
JOHN ZERATSKY: So here's
another small thing that's
easy to implement.
It's not necessarily going to
be important for all of your
users, but certainly
for some of them.
It's tab order, right.
You're going to have a series
of fields in a form that people
are going to go through in a
predictable way most likely.
So the tab order
should mirror that.
In this case you know,
physically on the page at least
in left to right language, the
fields are username and then
password and then the
sign-in button and then the
remember me checkbox.
This is from Twitter.
Presumably they put them in
this particular arrangement
because they thought it looked
good for aesthetic reasons.
But if you're using this,
you're not going to click
the sign-in button before
you check the remember
me checkbox, right.
So if you are typing, using the
keyboard and tabbing, you
actually want to go in a
slightly different order.
So the developers at
Twitter took the time
to say, you know what?
You're going to type in your
username and then your password
and then if you want the
remember me option you actually
have to check that before you
hit the blue button, right?
So they got the tab order right
so that it mirrors the way that
people are actually using it.
Two other quick ideas that we
don't have examples of, Matt
mentioned earlier generally
big click targets on mobile
and on desktop, really,
really useful thing.
If you've got a form make sure
that people can submit the form
by pressing enter, right?
They don't have to use the
mouse and find a button.
If you have keyboard shortcuts
in your application, if there's
some consistent standard for
how those shortcuts should
work, you know, use those.
Don't make people
relearn things.
And just for fun, let's talk
about a few offline examples.
The thing on the left is an oil
filter, but it's got this
really annoying plastic
packaging on it, right?
That you're going to have
to get out the biggest
scissors in your house
or some kind of knife.
You're going to have to wrestle
with it and open it up.
It's really, really
frustrating.
It's just the packaging.
I mean, I'm sure it's cheap and
easy for them to make, but it's
really hard for you as
the customer to open.
While I was browsing around
Flickr I also learned that
you can open these things
with a can opener.
I didn't know that, but
it's a tip for you guys
to use when you get home.
Life hack.
Amazon knows that packaging can
be a source of frustration, so
they invented frustration
free packaging.
So you buy this toy and instead
of having to deal with this
plastic wrapping that's all
around every single piece of
the pirate ship you get a
nice cardboard box, right?
You can open it up, take
your toy out, you or
your kid is happy.
And finally, some things are
supposed to be slow like
food and drink, right?
You're at a restaurant, you
don't want to be rushed along.
I haven't thought of any web
app examples that are supposed
to be slow, but you know,
maybe you guys will.
MATT SHOBE: Perhaps web chess
or something to that effect.
Principle two, be yourself.
Sounds simple, I realize.
What I think this is all of us
giving ourselves permission to
let a little bit of the spirit
of the team that creates
the thing appear in
the thing itself.
And that can take many
different forms.
It depends on the kind of an
application you're writing,
whether it's mobile.
Whether it's for the desktop.
Whether it needs to
communicate certain traits.
Security and trustworthiness
pretty useful for a financial
website or a banking
application.
Playfulness and engagement for
something that's more social
or more game oriented.
And empathy for an application
that may be used frequently in
a high-turnover, high-stress
work environment.
That's where the tips like set
the friggin' focus on the first
form in the field really come
in to save people minutes and
untold aggravation every day.
And I think essentially this
comes down to giving yourself
permission to do this.
And it's also I think a big
part of this is, if you have an
application that has a fair
amount of text and a fair
amount of either real time or
asynchronous communication.
In this case, there's a lot of
explaining going on or there's
a fair amount of text to
describe features that's an
opportunity for the personality
of the team, the personality of
the company and really it's
almost like a branding issue.
How do you want your product
to feel and be perceived?
That can come through
in the text.
And I think all too frequently
teams large and small don't
give themselves permission to
say it how they really feel and
they think, well we've got
to be corporate with this.
No, you don't necessarily have
to be corporate with this
because the people doing the
job may not be thinking
about the product that way.
But enough about that.
Let's take a look
at a few examples.
Brizzly is a service I'm
sure some of you use.
Allows you to see Twitter and
Facebook and multiple accounts
from each in one
web application.
It's a great sort of a social
aggregater I guess I'd call it.
And they've got a 404
page like many other 404
pages in all the land.
It lets you know that what you
tried to visit isn't there
for whatever reason.
What they do that I think is
smart here is I think they
realized they have a generally
text savvy or early adopter
oriented audience
at this point.
They don't need to
over-explain what happened.
They've got their branding
element with the Brizzly bear
there, which is kind of fun.
It's like OK, well there's
not a page here, but
hey, he's smiling at me.
And example number three, this
web server's bonkers right now.
I think that's an explanation
that pretty much you don't need
to say much more than that.
That that might be
exactly what's going on.
At FeedBurner we had a 404 page
that said trouble at the mill.
And that infuriated a number of
people just because it didn't
provide a proper explanation
for what might be going on.
We did provide more detail
further down the page, but
there are cases where too much
detail and no way to act on
it is not going to
be a good thing.
And in this particular case
it's like OK, I'm going to
try this again later or
try some other website.
JOHN ZERATSKY: And Brizzly can
pull it off because it's
fundamentally not a super
serious application.
MATT SHOBE: That's true, but
if you're trying to pull your
bank account together than
maybe that's not so hot.
So a few other examples that
we found here and there.
In Gmail, I think awhile ago
maybe now, I'm not even sure,
you could select to have
somebody show in your chat list
depending on how often that you
e-mail them and just
finishing with the status
message, it's magic.
That's great just don't
over-explain these things if
it's kind of a cool feature and
you don't need to go into much
detail and it's kind of cool to
just say, hey it's
this thing we did.
That kind of language I think
is totally appropriate.
Again, the tone of your
application needs to reflect
what it needs to reflect.
Now AdSense, somewhat more
serious application.
People are using
it to make money.
To manage what they publish and
in some cases they're living
online and in this particular
example it's an alerts box that
had important account level
messages and error messages
that you needed to act on.
There weren't any found.
You can just say,
no alerts found.
You can go play outside.
Maybe come up with two or three
different messages you might
show there if everything's done
and there are no
alerts in here.
Even though this is a serious
application, this is exactly
the sort of playfulness that I
think you can tweak into it
without doing yourselves harm.
And in fact creating a little
better engagement, a little
better emotional connection
with your users.
And finally the last one,
somebody must have punched
the history racer button,
so are you sure you
want to forget history?
If you do you'll be
doomed to repeat it.
You can get away with a joke or
a pun here or there if it's an
application that's not doing
something too serious, but in
this particular case-- I don't
know where we found this one,
but it doesn't really matter.
I don't know what was going to
get deleted there, but it's
another one of those examples
of stuff that you can make
happen that should
have a fun effect.
JOHN ZERATSKY: All right, so
one way to improve the user
experience of your product is
to actually engage in
conversations with your
users or potential users.
When you do this
people like you more.
They're more willing to forgive
you and they see you as kind
of being on their side.
It sort of takes away that wall
between developer and user.
And you're all sort
of in this together.
Of course companies haven't
always engaged directly in
conversation with
their customers.
But starting in early 2000s a
lot of companies started to
have blogs so that they could
respond to other blog posts,
so that they could host
comments on their own site.
And obviously as you're all
aware since then there's been
an explosion of ways for people
to talk about us as developers
and for us to talk back to
them when it's appropriate.
So the first important tip
here is simply to listen
to what people are saying
about your product.
And perhaps more generally.
This is all about monitoring
those various conversations
that are happening about your
company or your product.
Whether it be on blogs,
Twitter, Facebook, the
list goes on and on.
You know, just to run through
some simple tools here,
many things I'm sure
you've heard of.
Google Blog Search gives you
near real-time results about
what people are saying.
Technorati, same basic idea.
Has been around for years
and for good reason.
It's a really useful way to
track what people are saying
about your product
or your company.
And Twitter of course.
Twitter lets you do a search,
save that search so it's
easy to get back to.
I particularly enjoy tracking
these sorts of things on
Twitter because I think it
gives you access to a different
type of information then
you would see on a blog.
It allows you to see things
that are too new for people
to have made much of a stink
about it or too small.
You know, they figure this
is a minor annoyance.
It's not worth writing an
e-mail to the developer, but
I'm just going to post about it
on Twitter and if that's
something that you can see and
say hey, actually I've got an
idea for how to fix that.
You know, that can have a
really great impact on the user
experience of your product.
So provided you've been
using these tools.
You've been listening.
You know what people are doing.
You know, sometimes it's
appropriate to respond.
And when you do it's very
important to respond with
honesty and humility.
And Matt's got a great
anecdote to back this one up.
MATT SHOBE: So this was
early 2006 with FeedBurner.
Feedburner was growing
as a service.
We were identifying publishers
large and small to work with
and we were also adding new
staff and bringing them onboard
with how we do things.
And again, I mentioned some of
the things we do you earlier
was a lot of folks in the
company were involved in
providing direct
product support.
Everyone was generally pretty
engaged with what's going on
with the business if not
helping our users directly
in some form or another.
And one of the new employees
that came on, one of his jobs
or one of his responsibilities
was to build some of that
publisher engagement and get
some of the bigger publishers
to start using some new
services we had for publishers
and eventually get them
involved in our ad network.
At the same time, FeedBurner
had a very straightforward,
very simple privacy policy,
which was at registration time
we said, gives us your e-mail
address, we won't spam you.
Honest.
Ever.
And that was just that it.
We would never mean to contact
a publisher unless they
contacted us first, for
example, for support with an
issue with their account
or their feeds.
So this employee put
together an e-mail.
Sent it to I think 90
of our top publishers.
It was a very well written
e-mail explaining that we have
some new features and some new
capabilities that are coming
together and we'd like to
get them involved in it.
And I don't know, 5, 10 minutes
after that e-mail went out late
on an evening of some kind,
there were blog posts straight
away saying hey, I just got
some spam from eedBurner, WTF--
and I think that stands
for where's the fire.
And immediately those of us
with the keyword searches with
Technorati and if we had powers
to see the future we would
have seen the Tweets.
Saw those posts, got out there,
made some comments, but
our CEO [? DeKaslo ?]
figured out, well we need to
post about this right away.
We need to say something
because we aren't going to be
able to respond here, here,
here, here, and here.
So he put a blog post out there
that was an extension of
a comment that he put
on one of the posts.
And I'll just point out, we're
very quick to promote our own
success around here and we sign
deals and work with great
customers, so we have to look
ourselves in the eye and
challenge ourselves
when we screw up.
So we basically said, this
is not how we do business.
It's a mistake, it's
a cultural issue.
We need to help people
understand how we do things,
we're not going to do
it again, we're sorry.
This happens to be one
particular scenario
where this happened.
I think what you do when you
have a general openness and
transparency about responding
like this, you buy yourself a
second chance when you screw
up and you're going to
screw up at some point.
This I think just gives you a
better chance of an out and in
this particular case the
bloggers in question, again, 90
of our higher profile
publishers said, OK, yeah, we
know that's not how
you guys do this.
We've seen what your
personality is in your site
from the way you've
communicated before and the way
you've generally run things.
This does feel like it was a
one-time thing and thanks
for clearing that up.
Also I think Dick's in a
session at 3 o'clock today
and hopefully he'll be
signing Blackberries or
something like that.
We'll see.
Surprise.
So I'm currently a User
Experience Designer with Google
working still on our publisher
tools and I guess the example
here is the mobile one.
Yeah OK, for some reason I
was thinking I was going to
go to the other example.
No, this is good.
There was a set of our
publisher tools that we
created a mobile version for.
Somebody had an idea, there
was kind of a hackathon.
We took one week aside from our
regular responsibilities and
said, let's build a mobile
version of this part
of this application.
And it would be perfect for
this situation where we need
to stop these things from
happening or go investigate
them or put a star on them
later so you can go look at
them when you get to the office
in front of a proper desktop.
And this is one of these
higher stress, more
repetitive type jobs.
So it's one of these cases
where the more control you
feel you have over the
situation the better.
So we designed and built
this thing in about a week.
We're starting to test
it with a few people.
And then three days later,
somebody saw a Tweet.
So here we are in
the present day.
Got a Tweet saying, I sure wish
Google would launch a mobile
version of that thing.
And so somebody from the team,
like two hours later said,
hey, you want to come to
the New York office on
Wednesday and test it?
And the guys like, huh, sure.
Sure, I'll come in
and so he came in.
He give us some great feedback.
Changed a few things
about the design.
We were going to test it at
some point eventually, but we
saw this Tweet out in the
wild and basically got
some good feedback.
He walked away happy.
We were happy to have an
opportunity to have something
lucky like that happen and by
surprise your users I guess
I'm not saying wait for
serendipitous opportunity.
Like, we had a hackathon and
then somebody Tweeted that
they wanted the exact
same feature to happen.
But the more attention you pay
to the conversations that are
going on out there, the
likelier you are to make your
own luck and end up in
a situation like that.
And I forget what comes next.
Yes, well as far as surprise
and delight is concerned, swag
is a powerful motivator.
It's kind of a
branding issue too.
If you have a logo or you have
elements of your application
that you can distribute
as stickers.
Stickers are great to get out
there If you have spontaneous
meetups or community developer
events that you're involved
with and your product can have
a few things along with it to
move your brand and your
message and move your sort of
look and feel out in the world
it's a great way to do it.
And delighted users are
a good thing to have.
And this is one of the
easiest ways to do it.
I know almost all of us will
do anything for a t-shirt.
I know I still will.
It seems to be
eternally effective.
So sort of continuing on this
general theme of providing your
own support, sometimes you
don't have a choice because
again, it's that two guys
and a van scenario.
No one's going to provide
support except you.
It's a great way to stay
connected to what's going
on with your product.
What ideas people
might have for it.
What's going wrong right now.
The pain that's something you
built and deployed to
production is causing somebody
else is a pretty solid direct
line motivator for you
to go fix that thing.
And make the fix happen, so
that's a good thing to do.
And as far as platforms
who are doing that.
There are a variety of
ways of doing that.
There's of course, paying
attention to those
conversations and Twitter and
Technorati and so forth.
But for having a conversation,
you could install your own
forum or bulletin board
software. phpBB is what we used
way back when with FeedBurner.
We use groups now with
the Google version.
There are lots of
platforms with this.
Get Satisfaction we point out
is one that has it support
forums that end users as well
as employees visit and manage
and interactive in and work
for multiple products.
So I believe one log-in at Get
Satisfaction will work for you
for multiple products
that you might use.
That's convenient.
And in general, if you have a
platform like this or something
well-defined these people that
keep coming back again and
again, these early testers that
you meet that you end up with
direct e-mail conversations
with and folks that seem like
they really get it, they're
really interested in the space
you're working in or the mobile
application you've got or
whatever your technology is,
they'll go out and help other
people and ask you for help in
giving help to those other
people and they sort of become
super friends or super users
that you can then use the
t-shirts and the swag and so
forth to reward for
their service.
And if you give them a platform
for this it's a way to kind of
handle the scaling issue
of customer support.
Let's say things go well and
things go well beyond your
ability for the two, four,
eight, twelve, or even however
many of you there are to handle
that can't be focused on
support because I realize
that's not realistic for
every organization.
So platform is good.
And I'm going to continue
the streak here.
Principle four, be willing
to give up control.
So what this really is, is not
invented here is kind of a
thing that I think is a problem
for many of the people in the
room because we all use
third-party-- almost all
of us probably use some
third-party libraries.
We freely share code.
We use various other
third-party services to
make things happen.
I mean, that's fairly
common with us.
But this also applies to things
like, I'm not very good at
accounting or invoicing, I'd
like somebody to handle that.
You might hire somebody of
course to do that in your
office, but if that's not an
option there may be some
application you find that can
help make that work for you.
For our specific example, at
FeedBurner we had a fairly
strong sense of brand and
design and color palette that
we established early on.
That was the
relatively easy part.
The harder part was if we
needed illustrations for
particular seasonal events or
launches, certain blog posts,
and creative material, none
of us had illustrator or
photographer level talent.
None of us had anything beyond
the ability to put together
decent interaction design and
make the web graphics, but a
resource like iStockphoto is a
great place to go for you
to find those elements.
There are lots of illustration
[? permittives. ?]
Lots and lots of photographs.
Lots of bits and pieces that
can help support whatever
the goal is that you
want to accomplish.
This is the case where if you
decided to try to do all that
inhouse you'd be spending
probably an awful lot of time
coming up with not so great
stuff when something
excellent is out there.
There's one risk that we've
talked about with this before,
which is, well what if somebody
else uses the same infographic
to communicate their
big product launch?
That's pretty low risk.
And you're going to find a set
of artists or creators that
really match up with what you
think your personality is and
you're going to kind of go
to them again and again.
And you're going to kind
of own that look and feel
after some period of time.
And I just don't think
that's a big enough risk
to really worry about.
All right, and now politeness.
JOHN ZERATSKY: So the fifth
principle that we want to
talk about is to be polite.
This is kind of an odd
one, so let me give
a little background.
First of all I need to give
credit to Erica Hall,
who is a designer and
founder at [? Mill ?]
Design, a design agency
in San Francisco.
Because she gives a really
great presentation called
copy as interface.
The point of this presentation
is that the majority of the
interfaces that we use day to
day in high-profile,
popular applications are
mostly text, right?
So most of what we're seeing
and interacting with as
users is actually text.
So we really need to pay
attention to the text that's
in those interfaces.
She has a variety of different
pieces of advice for doing
this well, but the one that I
really like is to be polite.
And to a certain extent this
is common courtesy, right?
You want to design things that
are considerate of your users,
that are friendly, right?
You want to put yourself in the
mind of your users and walk
through your application or
walk through a given experience
and say, where would
this be annoying?
Where would this
piss me off, right?
And think of it in that way.
So here's an error message
I saw the other day.
Not really, but I mean, there
are many error messages out
there in the wild that
really aren't a whole lot
better than this one.
They tell you something is
wrong, but they don't really
give you a way to find
out more information or
figure out how to fix it.
And apart from the message
itself this OK/cancel
combination is rarely useful.
Especially in an error message.
It can leave you sort of
feeling like you don't
have any control.
There's nothing you
can really do.
It doesn't matter which button
you're going to press.
So of course, you don't need
me to tell you not to write
unhelpful error messages.
So let's talk about
some hopefully more
interesting examples.
For the first tip here about
being polite is to make it easy
for people to get started.
You know, again, this is
sort of common courtesy.
If we were going to start
having a conversation, we
wouldn't kick it off by asking
each other for date of birth
and mother's maiden and maybe a
credit card number, right?
We'd start talking, if we need
to collect more information
like a phone number we
would certainly do that.
So why would you do something
like that with your
web application?
Not that any of you do,
of course, but I've
seen it out there.
This is a really great example
of a smart way to do this.
Tripit is a website that
allows you to save and share
your travel itineraries.
And one way you can get started
using that site is to actually
forward your e-mail
confirmation that you get from
a site like Expedia or directly
from an airline, just forward
that to plans@tripit.com and
what they'll do is they'll get
your e-mail and they'll parse
out all the information about
your flight or your hotel or
whatever it is and they'll send
you back an e-mail.
And they'll say hey,
we got your e-mail.
We've created you a shell
account, we've put your
information in it, if you'd
like to use Tripit going
forward just click on
this link and sign up.
So that's a really nice, simple
and clever way of making it
very easy to get started
with an application.
Things like OpenID can make it
really easy to get started
provided that your users have
an OpenID and know what it is.
But there are other
options as well.
There's Google and Facebook
and Twitter all have these
federated sign-in options.
And the reason this is good is
that people don't have to
create yet another account.
When they get to your site
they can use something
they already know.
It's easy for them to remember,
get started right away.
Generally people don't
like creating new
accounts for things.
And they're not very good at
remembering arbitrary strings
of text, you know,
passwords, right?
So they tend to use the same
password over and over.
So not only is it a frustrating
experience, it's also kind
of a security problem.
On the flip side, it's not
enough to just make it
easy to get started.
You need to make it easy for
your users to leave or stop
doing whatever they're
doing in your application.
So make it easy for them to
sort of cancel their account
and leave, give them a way
out or a way to cancel
whatever they're doing.
People don't like to feel
trapped, so if you can avoid
building dead ends and dark
alleys into your product,
they're going to be
much, much happier.
Matt brought up an example
recently that is kind of like
the original example of this
principle, which is you
remember those top of page
links you use to see on a lot
of long webpages back in the
90s when people didn't want to
have a link to a new page
so they'd use anchor
links a lot, right?
I guess this was before they
invented scroll wheels or
something so it was not that
easy to get back up to the top.
But just when you're feeling
like, I'm sort of a long
way down this page, right?
Oh, there's a very convenient
top of page link.
So that's the basic idea.
It certainly has
evolved since then.
Here's something that's
actually really, really
common on the web
today, which is great.
Which is providing a very
simple, clear way to cancel
whatever action you
are about to take.
So whenever you have something
like save changes, have
cancel and don't save.
It's important to not only
have cancel, but explain
what that means.
If you cancel, what is
not going to happen?
You're not going to
save in this case.
Let's talk a little bit about
making it easy for people
to leave a service.
This is Brizzly yet again
and their sort of account
cancellation experience
is very straightforward.
It's right there on
your settings page.
It's easy to find.
And the thing I like about
it is that these use
really clear language.
The button says, delete this
Brizzly account forever.
It's very clear about
what's going to happen.
You don't have to worry.
It sounds immediate, right?
It's a very polite way to
handle account cancellation.
Netflix has really taken
this to a new level.
They have a very sophisticated
design for allowing people
to leave their service.
So the ability to cancel your
Netflix account is also
on their settings page.
It's also very easy to find.
Even more prominent
than Brizzly.
It's right at the top here.
And not only do they have a
clear cancel link right here,
but they have the option to
put your membership on hold.
And this is really nice.
Because you know,
sometimes you're moving.
You're on vacation.
You just don't feel like having
DVDs sent to your house for
awhile and so why pay
for that, right?
Why not put your
membership on hold?
That's a very considerate, very
polite thing for them to offer.
But let's say you do
click cancel membership.
You go to this next screen,
which sort of explains what
this means, what's
going to happen.
You've got to send
your DVDs back.
Don't worry, we're not going
to charge you anymore.
But the thing that I really
like here is that at the very
bottom it says, you'll still
have the option to restart
your membership at any time.
And this is really nice.
You know, they're not
sort of guilting you.
They're not sort of saying,
well you can cancel your
account, but we're going to
delete all your data and you
know, you're going to have
to recreate it next time.
They make it really easy for
you to come back, which is
again a very considerate
design on their part I think.
MATT SHOBE: Prepare
for failure.
Well, it's not as simple is it
sounds in this case, but we
might have heard this one
before thinking about fast
failure or concept of well,
we're going to move quickly.
We're going to see
if this is right.
If it's not right, we'll
do another iteration.
We'll make a change to this.
We'll make this gray instead
of blue and eventually
it'll work out.
That's fast failure.
That makes a lot of sense.
What we're talking about in
this case really has a lot more
to do with weird scenarios, I
think blind alleys or dark
alleys, blind exits, forks in
the road, sticks in the mud.
That sort of thing.
Odd interactions as well as
things that are totally out of
your control that you can
prepare for in order to
essentially keep your service
up and running or make sure
things are still available
and working as close to
correctly as possible.
As well as weird little
interaction situations such as
the first example that you may
not see unless you start doing
some usability testing or start
using the thing in the wild.
So this is a security dialog
from Mac OS and there are
situations where if you're
really quick with the
keyboard you can get
this dialog to appear.
This actually happens on
log-in, general log-in more so
than this particular dialog,
but this is for effect.
You start, type in your
username, you tab to the
password field, you start
typing, the system says, oh,
I'm going to set the focus on
the name field, but you were
already ahead of it before it
called that event and then set
the focus back on the name
field so your password just
starts to show up out there in
clear text because it
switched the focus back
without asking you.
JOHN ZERATSKY: Is
that your password?
MATT SHOBE: Totally.
So there's a fair amount of my
personal information in the
next few slides so please
try to pay attention.
JOHN ZERATSKY: Get
your notebooks ready.
MATT SHOBE: Yep.
So 23 Skidoo Street-- so in
this case you could make sure
that if somebody has the
password field and is typing
in it, don't take the focus
from the password field.
Something you wouldn't think
about because you're like, oh
we're going to set
the name field.
Nobody's ever going to get
ahead of it, but in practice if
the system works with the
timing in such a way that this
can happen you need to make
sure that you handle
that sort of thing.
So messy data entry.
Why force me to enter the
parens and the em-dash
or the dash-em-dash.
Or the dash or the http prefix
if you need to give me a
website address or I need to
give you a website address.
Or in I think a number of
cases, I don't even need to
indicate it's a Visa, I
can just start typing the
credit card number, you're
going to figure it out.
If you can do this sort of
stuff for data entry,
especially repetitive stuff--
people are in here doing this
every day and it's not like a
one-time account setup feature,
even then you still want to do
it because I just want to make
it as quick as possible for you
to fill out this form and not
throw an error message, cause a
failure to happen that we
didn't need to validate for.
Make messy data entry as
possible as it can be for
the user and it'll
make them happier.
Again, this is kind of
empathy sneaking in here.
Is that you've tried to
absolutely make sure that bare
minimum error cases are the
ones that you're going to
report on and stop somebody
from making progress.
I like this particular example
just because it shows kind
of readiness for anything.
BBC always has a high and low
graphics version of I think
all their major new sections.
I'm not sure how
deep this goes.
The low graphics version will
render on just about any
device, which is nice to
have generally speaking.
You almost always know you
can go to slash low there
and get to that content.
The high graphics version of
course is whatever bells and
whistles they care to deploy.
But let's say there's a
bandwidth spike, there's a
major news story, something big
is coming, let's say you're
about to do a major product
announcement and you know your
homepage is going
to get slammed.
You might just want to have
a plan B homepage that
makes sure that the news
still gets through.
It seems obvious, but plenty
of times people don't
think about it.
They don't prepare for this
particular kind of failure,
which in this case is something
that could've been very good,
goes horribly wrong because
you weren't ready for it.
And having that alternative
case ready to go could save
you a lot of heartache.
And well there's the fail
whale from a year or two ago.
This is actually an
image from iStockphoto.
And this became sort of famous
for well something has happened
with Twitter at this point and
we're not going to be able to
get the Tweets to you for a
little while, but we'll be
back as soon as we can.
And it became something of
a cultural phenomenon.
It became certainly something
that folks at Twitter-- well, I
guess if they could've Tweeted
about it, they would've Tweeted
fail whale as a trending topic.
It was one of those things that
simply became a recognized icon
from when things weren't quite
going wrong or weren't
quite going right.
And it essentially gave them,
certainly not over explaining
what was going wrong, but it
gave them at this point in
time a fairly familiar way
of saying, OK, here's the
thing that's happening.
You know what's happening.
We're going to get it
back up and running
as soon as possible.
Meanwhile, iconic image for
you, which led them of course
to eventually start working
on what supports our
seventh principle.
JOHN ZERATSKY: Which
is to be reliable.
In a sense we've kind of
brought this presentation
full circle.
I started out by talking about
latency, which is a technical
factor that has a big effect
on the user experience.
Reliability is the same way.
Nothing's more aggravating
than software that crashes
or a website that goes
down unexpectedly.
Especially when it's something
that you really rely on.
Of course, the stakes
are higher for certain
types of applications.
You know, we've talked a
lot about banking and
those sorts of things.
If your banks website is
unavailable or acting sort of
erratically, not only are you
not going to trust that
website, you might actually
not trust the bank, right?
So this sort of thing could
have a really huge impact on
that company's reputation.
And as Matt mentioned, to sort
of flip this Twitter example on
its head, you know, the fail
whale and their error page that
was very nice to look at, it
was very friendly, it was cute.
Definitely had a positive
impact on the user
experience, right?
Making a bad situation
slightly less bad.
But the real improvement
came from when they focused
on reliability, right?
They committed as a team to
making the service much more
reliable, to making it
something that you can
depend on and it paid
off big for them.
Partially as a result I
think of the reliability
improvements.
Twitter is now not
seen as a toy.
It's seen as an essential
tool for a lot of people.
It's seen as this incredible
platform for communication.
And now it's at the point where
I can't remember the last time
that I saw the fail whale
except for when I was making
this presentation of course.
So that wraps it up.
We talked about
seven principles.
We scattered some tips and
some examples in there.
The first one to be fast.
Not only should your
application be fast, but you
should allow your users to
be fast at using it.
You should be yourself.
You should let the spirit
and the personality of
the developers come
out in the product.
That wil give you
a point of view.
It will give your users
something to relate to.
Engage in conversations
with your users.
Figure out what they're
experiencing, what they're
going through, and
talk with them.
Be willing to give up control
in those cases where it can
actually result in a
better experience.
Like where you get your artwork
from somewhere else because
you can't do it yourself.
Be polite.
Be considerate.
Think about things from the
perspective of your users.
Make it easy for them
to get started.
to leave or get out of
whatever they're doing.
Prepare for the likely event
that your users will fail, will
run into a problem while
they're using your application
and try to work around that.
And finally, be reliable.
So that your users can
actually use the product
that you created.
Thank you.
That's it.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Great talk.
And there's just two things
that I keep running into and
wondering, how hard is it to
tab to the state drop down and
let people use the keyboard to
actually enter their state
instead of having it
automatically to go to the zip
code and then you have to use
the mouse to go back?
JOHN ZERATSKY: That's a great
example of one of those tiny
little things that like very,
very little effort would be
required to make
that work right.
AUDIENCE: And as far as failing
I keep running into websites
where you have to have Flash in
order to even see the site.
There's no way past the Flash
page to get into the site.
JOHN ZERATSKY: That's
another great example.
AUDIENCE: Don't they want
us to look at the site?
JOHN ZERATSKY: Yeah, thank you.
I'm going to open up the
Wave here in case anybody
put questions there.
AUDIENCE: For the save and
cancel slide that you guys
had up there, on the form
development you actually
had a button in text.
Can you guys tell me about a
little bit on the decision tree
on why you guys prefer buttons
in certain situations
versus text?
Is it via success rate
in trying to guide the
user through a process?
Or I don't know I've seen a ton
of things and reasons why,
I was just wondering what
you guys have behind it.
JOHN ZERATSKY: Yeah, that's a
very specific sort of design
issue, but generally my
thinking on that is that
buttons are good for an action.
Something that's really
going to do something.
In that case the link is
the opposite, right?
The link is not doing anything.
It also just comes
down to visual focus.
You know, generally a button's
going to be heavier visually
than a link, so people are
going to see it and recognize
that as the primary action.
And finally, just the simple
matter of click target
and size, right?
A big button is going to be
easier to click than a small
cancel link and so you don't
want people accidentally
hitting that cancel link.
If you had two buttons that
were the same size right next
to each other it'd be pretty
easy to either mess up and hit
the wrong one or you know,
you'd have to sit there and
sort of squint and say,
OK which one's the one I
really want in this case?
AUDIENCE: OK, a Google specific
question, do you guys actually
use like usability test labs
and actually run your users
through visual experience like
iTracking and things like that?
MATT SHOBE: Yeah, definitely.
JOHN ZERATSKY: At Google
we do the full gamut
of user research.
From very tactical, specific
usability testing and iTracking
all the way to ethnographic
studies where we just go to
somebody's office or go to
somebody's home and talk and
talk to them about how
their using products.
MATT SHOBE: And paper
prototypes and show a series of
my mocks and have people just
look around a conference
room in an afternoon.
Very scrappy stuff, too.
AUDIENCE: I noticed like my
users in my labs are actually
kind of put off on the fact
that they're in a lab, but
whenever I get way better
results from anything
I resolved.
JOHN ZERATSKY: Yeah, we didn't
really talk about research here
and I kind of wish we had a
little bit, but it's
important to sort of have a
good cross-section.
You don't want to be overly
reliant on one research
technique or it's going to
affect the results
that you get.
AUDIENCE: I'm guessing you
guys are huge on remote
usability testing.
What do you guys actually use
for getting users across
the globe to test?
JOHN ZERATSKY: I
don't actually know.
I know that we do it.
I don't know the specific tools
that we use for that though.
MATT SHOBE: You mean
the WebEx equivalent?
JOHN ZERATSKY: Yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
MATT SHOBE: I can't
even remember.
Where's [? Tomar ?]
when you need him.
What is the name of that thing?
If I can dig that up in
the next 15 minutes
I'll get back to you.
I know it's a Windows
based client that we
were typically using.
No the controls on our end
were Windows based, but
anybody could use it.
There's was a Java applet of
course on the other end, so
any platform could
use it to sign-in.
AUDIENCE: OK, we use
something called [?
Userview ?], but it was
limited to Windows.
Our Mac based users
or [INAUDIBLE].
MATT SHOBE: Yeah, I
don't remember what
the heck it's called.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
That's right.
Yeah, Skype-- I've definitely
heard that before.
That it works really
well for that.
Yes sir?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, when you were
talking about making text
friendly, how do you
handle localizing text?
You know, where it says
something that's more cultural?
MATT SHOBE: Well that
is a challenge.
I think the reality of having
a personality of course it
has a lot of cultural
connotations to it.
Like I was thinking we had
a section on FeedBurner
that was my feeds blank.
And we'd always put some phrase
in there and it was typically
something vaguely seasonal or
it might have a slight baseball
reference or I stuck in a
TK-421-Y enter at your
post at one point.
And you know, that was for the
five people that got that.
And so that part of it is just
kind of saying we're not going
to be predictable here.
And I think if you have an
organization that is building a
product that's going to be
localized, you may simply not
get the same benefits in effect
unless your localizers
are in on it.
Whatever that sense
is can translate.
If there's a humorous aspect
to it that's always tricky.
I mean, I don't know that I'd
ever promise success there.
We want it to be whimsical
and playful and empathetic.
We want to feel like if you
could somehow communicate
to the folks that are
doing the translation.
Part of the apps need to read
like it's really on your side.
However that can be nuanced,
I'd take a chance at trying
to do that because that's
ultimately what you're trying
to communicate in any language.
JOHN ZERATSKY: It's
definitely harder though.
MATT SHOBE: Yeah, I
certainly don't have a
pat solution for that.
Although I hear our Russian
translator was hilarious.
AUDIENCE: Hello, I wanted to
ask if you had any experience
or tips when you're designing
for children, like
10 year olds.
I know they don't pay attention
to instructions or something
like that, so how would you
compare that when you're
designing for kids compared to
when you're designing
for adults?
JOHN ZERATSKY: Well, nobody
pays attention to instructions.
MATT SHOBE: I was going to say,
kids might actually do a better
job of reading the instructions
than any of us do.
JOHN ZERATSKY: That's not
something I have any experience
with unfortunately.
AUDIENCE: Any references
or ideas you think
is helpful for that?
JOHN ZERATSKY: You're probably
already aware of this, but I
know there has been an
explosion of applications
targeted at children,
especially for the iPhone and
iPad just because it's such
an immediate interface.
I'm sure you're familiar
with many of those.
I would look there just to
see some examples of what
other people are doing.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, some Google
website uses unexpected results
such as if you search something
on Google Maps for instance,
get you directions from New
York to Paris it says like swim
10,000 miles or I think it used
to be at Google Search when you
search for Chuck Norris it says
you don't find Chuck Norris
he finds you or something.
JOHN ZERATSKY: Right.
AUDIENCE: So what do you
think about that kind
of user experience?
MATT SHOBE: I'm for it.
As long as it doesn't get in
the way of something that's
life-threatening or mission
critical or high,
high frequency.
Nobody likes to hear
the same joke.
And you're not probably going
to run that same query 59 time.
Although you might be
interested to see if you get
different instructions.
This time try it butterfly
instead of back stroke.
That sort of thing.
That's actually one thing from
the be surprising principle
that we mentioned-- I forgot to
touch on, which is easter eggs.
Little in jokes when the right
things combined can be fun as
long as there sort of whimsical
and off to the side and don't
get in the way of whatever
the critical thing is
that you're doing.
And in this case you know I
think those searches are not
super critical although I guess
you could decide-- I'm not
sure how you actually
opt out of those.
JOHN ZERATSKY: Yes, so I think
in the case of the Maps one is
a really, really good one
because you're realistically
not going to use Google Maps
to figure out how to get
from New York to Paris.
It's not a realistic of use of
that tool, so that's a perfect
opportunity to inject a
little bit of humor.
The Chuck Norris thing, like as
long as the real search results
are also on the page, you know,
let's say you're actually doing
research about Chuck Norris
for some legitimate purpose.
You know, you don't want
to be blocked from
finding the results.
It's just fun.
MATT SHOBE: We'll make sure
the scholarly reports
still get through.
The awesomeness side is fun
to future up top if you can.
JOHN ZERATSKY: OK, I think
we've warned you down.
Thank you very much for coming.
MATT SHOBE: Thanks.